Welcome back everyone! I am super excited about
this lecture. This is a new one; I haven't given
this before in class but I've been meaning to for
a long time and it's all about the wave equation
which is one of the most important partial
differential equations in all of physics
it is everywhere and so I like to think about motivating the wave equation by thinking about
music and acoustics. So a guitar or a vibrating
guitar string is a really good example
of a wave equation that we're going to derive and
analyze and solve. So this is a two-part lecture
and in the first lecture i'm going to motivate for you:
what is the wave equation? where does it comefrom?
what are some examples? Literally
these examples are everywhere, from acoustics to
optics... you name it, it's everywhere. And we're
going to derive this wave equation from scratch
from first principles physics and then tie it
back to some intuitive examples like a vibrating
guitar string. So we're going to ask questions
like: why does tensioning the guitar
string making it... more tension make
it a higher pitch sound versus a lower pitch sound?
Things like that. Why are the thinner guitar
strings higher than the thicker guitar strings?
Why does changing the material from, let's
say steel to nylon, change things? That's all
an outfall of the wave equation. So I'm
going to come back to this in a little bit and for
right now i'm going to start by deriving
and explaining what I mean by the wave equation.
Good so maybe I'll use some colors here...
So the idea of this this wave equation
is that you have... I'm just going to write down
the equation u_tt = c^2 u_xx, where
u is going to be the height of some string so
we're going to assume that we have a string
that is pinned, let's say between two
locations, so this is going to be the
x=0 location and this is going to be
the x=L location. So that's the length of my
guitar string in this case, and what we're assuming
there's some rest position where the string
is under some tension but it's
not moving and we're defining u to be the height
or the displacement of this guitar string from
that rest position. So these are all my u(x,t)
Okay so the the displacement of that string
is a function of its position spatially along
the length of that string and it also changes
in time. You can picture this thing literally
oscillating... you
know the guitar string is
oscillating and that's what's creating
these acoustic waves... so that's one example
of the wave equation, is something like a vibrating
string. This is where the boundary conditions are
pinned so that both the x=0 and x=L boundaries are pinned to be zero displacement.
I think it's actually really interesting that
the acoustic waves that this vibrating string
generates these acoustic waves that you're hearing
from me talking or from that guitar string
vibrating... those also satisfy this linear
wave equation.
so even though acoustic waves are pressure waves traveling through a fluid
medium and we know fluids are governed by the
non-linear navier-stokes equations
acoustic waves are kind of infinitesimal
uh infinitesimal shock waves if you like they're
traveling at the speed of sound in the in the
medium whether it's air or water or helium and
those those pressure waves those shock waves are
infinitesimal so that they don't create any kind
of noticeable change in entropy as they travel
which is why acoustic waves travel such great
distances that's why you can hear you know an
airplane flying overhead from great distances
things like that okay i should mention that this
c here is the wave speed so maybe i'll just make
note of that so c equals let's say the wave speed
um and if if we're talking about acoustic
waves this would be the speed of sound
in the fluid medium if we're talking about
optics this would be the speed of light
in a given a given medium so that's another
example is optics okay so if i have let's say
this is my eye and i have light coming in you know
from some source and bending through my the optics
of my eye to hit my retina these plane waves
from maxwell's equations from electromagnetism
those are also governed by the linear uh second
order wave equation okay where you know the
second derivative of this uh fluctuation whatever
that fluctuating quantity is in time is equal to
the wave speed squared times its fluctuations the
second derivative of those fluctuations in space
so optics acoustics vibrating strings all of
these are governed by the wave equation i had
the guitar string which is pinned in two
places but if you also have something like
let's say i have i think every kid has done this
when they were you know young you take a rope
and you flick the rope and you send a traveling
wave down that rope so maybe it goes in this
direction in that case the boundary conditions are
a little bit different than the guitar string so
now one of my boundary conditions my hand is
forcing it at some profile in time and then
the other boundary condition if it's a very very
long rope you would assume is kind of uh you know
unpinned or free and so you get different
solutions to those uh those wave equations
but they're still governed by the same physics
whether depending uh on on the boundary conditions
uh what are some other examples um some of you
like to slackline i'm pretty sure and so if you
take a tree let's say you have a cool tree and
you have your slack line set up around this tree
and you are a human
on this slack line and so if you're anything
like me you're probably vibrating a little bit
uh and then also the string the kind of um the
cable that's connecting there's another tree
over here that's uh connected to the other side
this cable is also vibrating at some frequency
and so we're going to be able to understand so
we're going to derive this wave equation we're
going to see how this speed of the wave the wave
speed at least in the guitar string and this slack
line depend on things like the tension in the
rope or the tension in the string the thickness or
material properties of that string those are all
going to kind of go into this this wave speed c
but these are just some of the many many many
examples of how the wave equation comes up in
physics and in engineering i guess you know i
also think about if you throw a rock in a pond
you're going to get you know some kind of ripple
effect in that pond you know that's also going to
travel uh according to this this wave equation uh
with some some uh assumptions and simplifications
okay good so i'm going to start deriving this wave
equation i'm going to specifically derive it for
uh this kind of guitar string because that for me
is very intuitive and then we're going to analyze
the properties of of this equation and understand
how kind of the physics and the math tie together
so something i like to also point out is a little
bit of the history of this wave equation so this
wave equation in 1d as a partial differential
equation was written down by dallam bear i
think in 1746 this was not the first time that
a vibrating string was mathematically considered
that was done earlier by what brook taylor okay
so that was you know a decent bit earlier uh kind
of right after newton's f equals m a brook
taylor started analyzing vibrating strings
but the partial differential equation
was written down by dahlember in 1746
and then about 10 years later euler generalized
this to a full three-dimensional wave equation so
in 2d you can think of the membrane of a drum as a
two-dimensional wave equation in three dimensions
uh euler generalized this so that would be
like acoustic waves in three space traveling
in all directions uh and i guess in that case
this u x x would be replaced by a laplacian
of u operator okay which we've seen before in our
other examples of partial differential equations
good okay um so i think i'm going to
jump into this thing so this is the
uh the definition of what i mean by my
variable u it is the height of my guitar string
it could also be the the kind of amplitude of
my pressure you know wave if i'm talking about
acoustics um there's different you know meanings
of you and all of these different physical
scenarios but for here i'm going to zoom in on
this guitar string and just think about that and
and so what we're going to do is try to derive
this equation here from scratch and so what i
like to think about is at the end of the day the
the wave equation is actually one of the simplest
equations to derive uh in physics because it
really is just f equals m a it is the conservation
of momentum in this kind of elastic springy medium
now this is kind of a meaningful lecture for me
because it actually took me a really long time
in my mathematical career to feel comfortable and
confident kind of deriving and analyzing the wave
equation from scratch so you know i loved calculus
and differential equations when i was a kid and
i remember saving up my money when i was you know
a teenager to buy this differential equations
book it was the one differential equations book
that barnes and noble sold it was a really really
good book and i remember working through kind of
the ordinary differential equations and i got
to the section on partial differential equations
and it started with the wave equation and the
derivation of the wave equation always confused me
and i just got stuck time and time again you
know on two pages in to this section on partial
differential equations and eventually i just
kind of left it and didn't really revisit partial
differential equations until i was a grad student
and so years later now that i'm teaching this
material i think it's really important you know
to be able to derive these things from scratch
to really physically understand how they're
tied to simple concepts like f equals ma and
conservation and i just kind of want to demystify
how this is derived and analyzed because for me
uh you know this was kind of a mental block and
i'm telling you this because you know a lot of you
see me derive these things and it looks easy and
you don't maybe know that this took in this case
decades for me to really feel comfortable uh with
this derivation and also with kind of all the
physical interpretations and how to really uh kind
of manipulate this equation and understand how it
relates to things like a guitar string or a slack
line and things like that good so f equals m a and
what we're going to do is we're going to zoom in
on a little uh teeny tiny section we're going to
look at a little section from x to x plus delta x
i'm just going to draw a kind of a little picture
over here where we have some section of this
and i hope i've given myself enough space here
from x to x plus delta x and this is a tiny little
infinitesimal section of my guitar string and
we're literally going to compute the forces uh
the masses and the acceleration on this little
section of string that's vibrating we're going to
make some assumptions about what can be happening
and then we're going to to derive things
so what are the basic assumptions here
the basic assumptions at least a
couple of the basic assumptions
are that we're going to assume
that gravity is negligible
or gravity is negligible compared to the tension
in the string gravity is negligible negligible
don't know how to spell negligible really compared
to tension in the string to string tension
good uh which means we're gonna you know tighten
this guitar string up so that when it's vibrating
the vibration is really only determined the
motion is only going to be these forces are
only from that string tension and gravity is
really negligible and you can kind of convince
yourself that this is true because if you play
guitar in kind of the normal upright position it
doesn't matter if you play it this way or if you
play it this way or if you play it you know if you
rotate it in any plane it's going to sound a bit
about the same because gravity has a negligible
effect on that guitar string um what are some
other assumptions some other assumptions i'm
going to make are that the deflections even though
i've drawn a really big kind of cartoonishly large
deflection we're going to assume that all of our
our deflections are small okay so deflections
deflections are kind of small and this is going
to allow us to make a small angle approximation
work so we're going to assume that all of
the kind of angles throughout this path
are small and it's going to allow us to make
a very very important third assumption which
is pretty much related which is that
the tension in this string is constant
throughout the string we have basically the same
tension everywhere in the string that's kind of
how tension works for small deflections so tension
uh is the same throughout throughout x okay so
at every x location i'm going to assume that the
tension in the string is the same and so so this
is an important variable to mention is that the
tension we're going to call this t and this is a
force okay so tension is literally a force in
that string so there is a tension vector here
t and there is a tension vector here t and
those are the same forces they have the
same kind of force t at the left side of the
segment and at the right side of the segment
and essentially what we're going to say is
that because i i again i drew this so that
it's not really a small angle that's just for
for visual uh to make it visually easy to see
but what we're going to assume is that these are
small angles and so the kind of x component are
approximately equal because cosine of those small
angles are about equal to one and so there's not
going to be any horizontal motion of the segment
there's only going to be a vertical motion
because of the vertical components
of these two tensions being different
and causing an acceleration so that's where
the force is going to come from is from the
vertical component of these two tensions at
the left and the right part of my segment
and the mass and the acceleration i'm going
to write down right now so the mass the mass
in this little segment we're going to say is
equal to rho delta x where rho is essentially the
density or let's say the mass per unit length so
this is called the linear density linear density
which is the mass per length and so this is you
know already we're going to start seeing that um
you know a thicker guitar string on the lower
uh for example e string is going to have a
larger linear density it's going to have more
mass per length than the the really small
kind of higher e string which is has a lower
mass per length so that's presumably going to
change kind of the wave speed and the sound that
those strings make okay so this is kind of all
that we need to start building the solution
now so literally mass is rho times delta x
and so mass times acceleration m a is just going
to equal rho delta x and in this case acceleration
is we're only talking about acceleration in the
vertical direction because that guitar string is
kind of you know oscillating this way at least the
way that i'm oriented and so a the acceleration in
time is just uh utt this is the second derivative
of u with respect to time the first derivative is
velocity the second derivative is acceleration
um you know in in that vertical displacement
direction so mass times acceleration is rho
delta x utt now i need to derive what my force
is equal to and i've already kind of alluded
uh that my force is going to be from the y
components of these two tensions not being equal
because the angles are not equal and so that's
what we're going to derive now so the force in
the y direction is going to be from these tensions
and i've seen this derived a number of different
ways and you know i kind of have my own favorite
way but there's no right or wrong way there's
lots of ways of coming up with the right answer
so what we're going to do is we're
going to call this angle here
theta and we're going to call this angle let's see
if i have enough room here theta plus delta theta
we're just going to kind of define you know this
angle here is theta plus delta theta this angle is
theta and we're going to say that the force in the
y direction the force i care about is um f equals
and i'm going to define it so that you know
this one is pulling in the you know kind of
positive direction this one's pulling in the
negative direction so minus t here plus t
here so the force is equal to t only the vertical
component so sine of theta plus delta theta minus
t times sine of theta that's the force in the
y direction okay and i could just take this
expression and say that equals rho delta x utt and
that's absolutely true that is newton's second law
that's conservation of momentum in this section
of the string but this expression here is not that
useful i want something that's u x x not something
in terms of theta so how do i get this u x x from
this expression here and the way that i do that
is again using the small angle approximation um
cosine of theta well so sine of theta is just
theta sine of theta plus delta theta is just
theta plus delta theta and cosine of both
of these are approximately equal to one
so if i divided both of these by cosine
of those angles that would be basically
dividing them by one and so because of this uh
small deflections a small angle approximation
we can essentially say that this is approximately
equal to t and now instead of sines i can just
replace these with tangents same same deal doesn't
it doesn't change anything so tan theta plus delta
uh delta theta that's a delta sorry minus tan
of theta okay so again just from the small
angle approximation this force is now my tension
times uh tan of this angle minus tan of this angle
but the kind of cool thing is and i think i
picked this up um you know watching watching
another lecture online and i hadn't realized
this since you know i guess i was a high school
student probably like it's something you learn
and then at least i forgot it is that tan of theta
this is super cool tan of theta of course is you
know the delta y over the delta x but that delta y
is is u so that's you know that's essentially
partial u partial x so partial u partial
x is tan of theta so this is essentially um
you know partial u partial x evaluated at
x plus delta x at time minus partial u partial x
evaluated at x at my given time t i'm going to say
this one more time we are you know we're saying
that the force that's accelerating this piece
of the string or the yeah the vibrating string
vertically is the vertical component of this
minus the vertical component of this so you know
t sine theta plus theta dot minus t sine theta
we can change those signs to tangents because of
a small angle approximation and now tan of theta
is essentially the the change of u with respect
to x partial u partial x partial u partial x here
minus partial u partial x here times tension is
the force in that spring the string this is the
force in that string and so now what we're going
to do is we're going to take this expression for
force and this expression for mass times
acceleration and set them equal to each other so
i'll do that now so i have and i'm going to divide
both sides by rho delta x so i'm going to get u t
equals this expression divided by
rho delta x so t over rho delta x
times sorry this is a squeaky marker
i know it drives some people crazy
partial u partial x evaluated x plus delta
x at time t minus partial u partial x
at x and t and now of course what we're
going to do is we're going to take the limit
as delta x goes to zero right we always
were assuming that this was going to be an
infinitesimal little section of of string uh of
of uh yeah like a guitar string and so now what
we're going to do is we're going to take the limit
as delta x goes to zero and the limit as delta x
goes to zero of this expression divided by delta
x is just the derivative of partial u partial x
with respect to x which is the second partial
derivative of u with respect to x i'm just
going to write this out this is uh maybe i'll
write it in pink you know and so now what we're
going to do is we're going to take the limit as
delta x goes to 0 of t over rho 1 over delta x
uh you know partial u partial x x plus delta x
at time t minus partial u partial x x in time
and so the limit as as uh delta x goes to zero
of this expression here is just you know the
derivative of this quantity of partial u partial
x so that's partial squared u partial x squared
so this thing here is just u sub x x you know
which we're defining as partial squared u
partial x squared and so now what we have
we have derived the wave equation we're at
the end where u t t u t t the second partial
derivative of u with respect to time this is
the kind of acceleration term is equal to t over
rho times u x x so this is the wave equation
where c squared equals t over rho okay the tension
divided by the linear density so this is really
cool um maybe i'll just do like a super quick
recap of how i derived this um in a little bit
but i want to point out that this was um
you know essentially very intuitive so now
what we have is we have this this wave equation
where the wave speed itself c squared um the
square of the wave speed is directly related to
the material properties of that guitar string the
tension in the string and the linear density okay
so we'll we'll revisit this in a little bit um and
in the next lecture of course what i'm going to do
is we're going to actually now solve this equation
for given boundary conditions so i'm going to take
again we're going to take the guitar string pinned
between x equals 0 and x equals l that's kind
of the length of the guitar string we're going
to pin it we're going to tension it up you know
so that we have some tension and we're actually
going to solve this wave equation using the
separation of variables very very powerful method
in partial differential equations my last video i
just put out was all about separation of variables
for partial differential equations for laplace's
equation for the heat equation now we're going
to do it for this wave equation okay which
is arguably even more ubiquitous right the
wave equation is everywhere from optics to guitar
strings to uh acoustics right let's say i'm on my
slack line and i'm whistling you know the acoustic
waves generated by that are also governed by this
extremely important uh wave equation a second
order hyperbolic partial differential equation
i'll tell you what i mean by hyperbolic uh in
a little bit i'm not this is not just hyperbole
okay good um so the quick quick recap of how we
solved uh or how we derived this wave equation
from scratch was that we basically zoomed into a
little infinitesimal segment of our guitar string
so this is the guitar string here it's a little
tiny tiny segment um you know from x to x plus
delta x we made some fairly simple assumptions
that the string is under enough tension that
gravity is negligible compared to the tension
so the dominant force is from the string tension
we've made the assumption that the deflections are
relatively small again so that you can use kind
of a small angle small theta approximation even
though i drew this with a really exaggerated theta
just to make it easy to draw you know if you look
at your guitar string it's really not moving a lot
compared to the length l and so these deflections
are small and those small deflections allow us to
make the uh further assumption that the tension
is relatively constant throughout the string
so the tension you know at the end that you you
twist you know the little thumb screw to increase
the tension that sets the tension uh at a constant
level throughout that entire guitar string
even when the string is moving so given those
assumptions you can essentially write down force
equals mass times acceleration f equals m a on the
segment and then by keeping careful track of what
all the forces are and what all the accelerations
and masses are you can derive this wave equation
okay so remember f equals ma is just conservation
of momentum uh you know you know concert in this
case vertical uh momentum of a little mass of
guitar string so the mass is rho delta x because
rho is the linear density so you know that linear
density times delta x gives you the total mass
in that segment the acceleration of that segment
in the vertical direction is u tt the second
derivative of u with respect to time because u is
its vertical position and so you know mass times
acceleration is kind of the easy part to derive
the force i mean it's not really that much harder
you take the the tension force which are always
tangential i guess that's another assumption i
should have made that's kind of an obvious one is
that the tension is always tangent uh to the you
know the curvature of that string and so basically
the fact that the string is bending throughout
this little uh delta x segment means that the
vertical component of my force on the left side
is not exactly equal to the vertical component of
the force on my right side and there is some net
vertical force accelerating uh this little bit
of string up and down that little net vertical
bit of force is given by t sine of theta plus
theta delta theta minus t sine theta the vertical
force on the right hand side minus the vertical
force on the left-hand side okay we're also of
course assuming because of this small angle
approximation that the cosine components the
kind of x components of these two forces are very
very nearly equal to each other and equal to one
because cosine of a small angle equals cosine of
this other small angle equals one we assume that
there is kind of no net force moving this thing
in the in the x direction just in the y direction
okay so our small angle approximation then goes
into this tangent you can basically turn these
signs into tangents because again dividing by
cosine doesn't do anything for small angles and
then we use this kind of neat little trick that
tan of theta is equal to partial u partial x it's
literally you know whatever delta in the vertical
direction which is my my u variable delta u delta
x and if i take that limit i get partial u partial
x and so now when i combine this force with this
mass times acceleration into one equation and
i take the limit as my delta x goes to zero
i recover that this uh this force component here
has to equal uxx my force is proportional to the
second derivative of u with respect to x which is
another way of saying the curvature of the string
in uh kind of with respect to that x uh
variable this is the curvature of the string
so higher curvatures kind of a sharper bend is
going to be a much bigger force that's going to
accelerate my strength that makes sense because my
string doesn't want to be really you know tightly
bent around a very very sharp point of curvature
okay and that's how we derived this equation
so last thing i'm going to do in this lecture
you know in the next lecture we're going to
solve this thing with separation of variables
last thing i'm going to do in this lecture
is revisit the guitar string and so i want
to think about if it makes physical sense
that you know how the tension changes things
and how the linear density changes things
so what i would expect is that increasing
the tension t should increase the speed
the wave speed c so if i you know if i
take my low e and i increase the tension
am i on the wrong one i'm on the wrong string
okay now you can hear it i'm increasing the
tension you can hear it's increasing that
wave speed now i haven't directly shown you
this is something i'll show you in the next
lecture when we solve this using separation of
variables remember when this string vibrates
the string itself is governed by the the wave
equation but it's also oscillating the air and
creating these acoustic waves which are also
governed by the wave equation and so kind of
as you know as the speed of information travels
through this this guitar string what i'm going to
show you is that uh kind of the the vibrational
frequency also depends on this uh c quantity
here it also depends on the length which is why
having a longer string would make this a lower
frequency and having a shorter string
would make it a higher frequency
okay good so increasing the tension makes
it a higher pitch decreasing the tension
makes it a lower pitch a lower wave speed okay
now let's talk about the linear density so the
linear density is literally you know how much
mass there is per unit length of string so my
thicker strings have a a higher linear density a
larger linear density than my smaller string just
literally because it has a smaller cross sectional
the smaller string is a small cross-sectional area
it weighs less per centimeter than my larger
string and so what that means is that my
larger string has a big row and so dividing by
a big number makes c lower so my my big string
has a lower wave speed than my small string
assuming that they're made of the same material
you know let's say they're both made of metal the
same metal now another way that you can change
this and that's actually how how these strings are
is that the three uh lower strings are made out of
metal and the three higher strings are made out
of nylon and so the nylon also has a lower linear
density so that's another way to make this number
smaller the lower linear density for those those
higher strings which makes them you know higher
pitch higher wave speed but without making them
teeny tiny so if you want your strings to be
you know just the same thickness but still be
higher pitched you can make them out of a lighter
material like nylon okay so these are all kind of
cool outfalls directly of you know the f equals
ma physics that went into deriving this wave
equation for this vibrating guitar string okay
so in the next lecture we're going to solve this
thing using uh separation of variables we're going
to still you know look at how that guitar string
vibrates we're going to look at how the
sound will change as we change things like
the length of that guitar string you know these
material properties i'm going to revisit this
once we you know actually look at the solution
of this wave equation and we're going to do that
using separation of variables this is probably
for me you know one of my favorite new lectures
because it took me you know a long time to feel
comfortable with this derivation and the solution
but now that i do it really is kind of a piece
of cake okay so i hope you find this uh as
interesting and as fun and as you know widely
applicable as i do all right stay tuned thanks